大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
這一集是耶魯大學賽局理論公開課的最後一集,
課號Econ159,
這次上第十期,
好到第二十四發,
講臺上還是Ben Pollack老師,
上集的答案是,
難的不是算出自己要什麼,
是算出別人會怎麼做,
終極的答案是,
難的不是眼前划算,
是長期划算,
終極最後留下一個問題,
當你根本看不到對方心理那件事的時候,
你還能不能算他有多急,
他說的話算不算數,
他到底是哪一種人,
這些都不會寫在他的臉上,
可是他們會寫在他的動作裡,
我先把答案放在前面能算
因為每個動作都在說話
難的不是看穿人心是讀懂動作
這些八堂課會分三步驟
先看看不見的東西怎麼改變算法
再看嘴上說的話什麼時候算數
最後看沒有明天的時候
一個動作憑什麼讓人相信
最後一堂課
Polak會讓一罐硬幣在教室裡傳
出價最高的那位同學會發現自己贏了
才是壞消息
這一題我們留到最後
先從那塊錢開始
Polak從口袋裡拿出一張真的一塊錢
走下講臺
在一排座位旁邊停下來
找了兩個同學
規則很短
第一個人說一個分法
自己留多少
給對方多少
第二個人只能做一件事
收或者不收
他收下
兩個人就照這個分法拿錢
他不收
兩個人一毛都拿不到
這個遊戲叫
Ultimatum Game
中文叫最後通牒賽局
叫它最後通牒
是因為第二個人
沒有還價的機會
只能點頭或搖頭
終極我們學過
逆向歸納
也就是從最後一步倒著算
這一題倒著算很快
我們先看第二個人
不管拿到多少
只要比零多
收下都比不收好
所以他應該什麼都收
再往前看第一個人
既然對方什麼都收
第一個人只要給一分錢
其他全部留下來就好
這就是理論的答案
一塊錢切成99分跟1分
你先想一下
如果你是第二個人
人家只給你一分錢
你會收嗎
教室裡發生的事
跟理論不一樣
第一組是Iquia跟Noah
Iquia照著理論做
給Noah一分錢
他的理由很合理
他覺得Noah拿一分錢
總比什麼都沒有好
Noah搖頭
他不收
兩個人都拿了零
Paulak站在走道上說
這樣我一毛錢都沒賠
好像還不錯
全班笑了
第二組換Anish開價
他大方一點
給Gary三十分錢
Gary也搖頭
Polak問他為什麼
Gary只回了一句
純粹是面子
Polak把獎金加大
換第三組
Courtney開了剛好一半
Danny收了
你注意Danny的理由
他說一半總比什麼都沒有好
可是同一句話
本來也該讓Noah收下那一分錢
Polak特別提醒
這不是耶魯學生比較怪
在實驗室裡
這是非常穩定的結果
太低的出價常常被拒絕
把錢加大也一樣會發生
理論給的預測很清楚
教室給的答案也很清楚
兩個答案對不上
所以理論錯在哪
Polak問全班
大概給了好幾個理由
有人說是面子
有人說是在跟對方比
你拿20分
看著對方拿80分
心裡不舒服
有人想給對方上一課
讓他下次多給一點
也有人想到名聲
大家都看了
你想讓人知道你不好欺負
這些理由有一個共同點
他們都不在那張分數表上
理論只算了錢
可是Noah心裡還有別的東西
那是Paulak看不到的
Noah沒有開口解釋
他只做了一個動作
搖頭
這個動作在說
我在乎的不只是錢
一旦大家知道泰迪的出價會被退回
出價靠近一半就很合理了
Paulak還提了一個更簡單的遊戲
叫Dictator Game
中文叫獨裁者賽局
它的規則是
第二個人連拒絕的權利都沒有
可是很多人還是會分不少錢出去
這一集會一直回到這件事
看不到對方心裡的時候
他的動作會說話
Polak接著改了一條規則
這一次第二個人如果不收
遊戲不會結束
換他來開架
第一個人決定收不收
不過餅會變小一點
因為時間過去了
這個變小的比例叫discount factor
中文叫折現因子
他的意思是
明天的一塊錢
在你今天眼裡不到一塊
譬如只值九毛
規則一改
同樣的人再玩一次
Iquia這次給Noah四十一分
Noah收了
從一分前跳到四十六分
中間沒有人教他們公式
為什麼跳這麼多
因為第二個人手上多了一樣東西
他可以不收
然後換他開價
第一個人要給的
是剛好讓他覺得不必等的數字
也就是他明天能拿到的東西
換算成今天的價值
Paulak又問Danny
剛才你要是不收
換你開價
你會開多少
Danny說
我會給他45分
Paulak轉頭問Courtney
你會收嗎
Courtney說會
也就是說
Danny要是等一輪
自己能留下的會比30分多
可是他剛才收下的只有30分
Paulak說
你本來可以做得更好
Polak把輪數一輪一輪往上加
只有一輪的時候先開價的人幾乎拿走全部
兩輪的時候
他要讓出對方明天能拿到的那一塊
三輪四輪每多一輪
就再倒著算一次
他在黑板上畫出來是一條一來一回的鉅子線
一步一步往中間靠
輪速推到沒有上限
而且兩個人可以很快的來回開價
去半小時就回一次
餅幾乎不會變小
這時候答案是
兩個人各拿一半
一開始那個大到不合理的先手優勢
被一輪又一輪的機會磨平了
可是這個結果裡
藏著一件更怪的事
有個同學看出來了
第一個報價就會被接受
沒有來回喊價
沒有討價還價
Paul Luck說
那些來回全部在我們腦子裡演完了
雙方都倒著算清楚了
第一個人直接開出那個剛剛好的數字
對方就收
你想一下
這跟你在菜市場
或者買二手車的時候看到的樣子
完全不一樣
真實世界裡
大家明明一直在殺價
真實世界為什麼會來回殺價
Paulak先挖出一個
他偷偷塞進去的假設
兩個人一樣有耐心
只要一邊很急
另一邊可以慢慢等
慢慢等的那一邊就會拿得比較多
Paulak舉了兩個例子
一個是研究生找到很遠的工作
下星期就走
車子帶不走
你知道他急
這臺車的價錢就會很不一樣
另一個是
那一年好萊塢編劇正在罷工
電視臺那邊最急的是深夜節目
他們明天就要David Letterman的稿子
可是編劇那邊要付房租
要養小孩
他們也急
Polak的結論是
錢比較少
而且被對方知道你錢比較少
你就會談到比較差的條件
接著有同學點出
最關鍵的一件事
真實世界裡
你不知道對方有多急
另一位同學補上
你也不知道那樣東西對他值多少
Polak說
所以你可能會故意拒絕
一個還不錯的報價
好讓自己看起來不急
你拒絕的那個動作
就是在告訴對方我等得起
來回殺架
其實是雙方用動作在互相試探
看不到對方心理
是一種看不見
還有另一種看不見
你看不到對方剛剛做了什麼
第18個
Polak一上來就說
今天沒時間玩遊戲
要學的東西很多
而且都很正式
他在黑板上畫了一棵樹
第一個人有三條路
上中下
他走完
第二個人才動
分數是這樣排的
如果第一個人走上或走中
第二個人看到了
就有辦法讓他拿0分
自己拿4分
所以第一個人倒著算一輪就知道
上跟中都不能走
他只好走下拿一分
然後Polak把同一棵樹再畫一次
形狀一樣
分數一個都沒改
他只多畫了一條虛線
把第二個人的兩個位置連起來
這條虛線有名字
叫Information Set
中文叫資訊集
他的意思是
第二個人知道第一個人沒走下
可是分不出他走的是上還是中
站在虛線上的人
知道自己在這幾個點的其中一個
只是分不出是哪一個
虛線一畫
第一個人多了一個原本沒有的選擇
他可以在上跟中之間亂數
一半一半
第二個人分不出他走哪一條
只能猜
一半的機會
第一個人拿四分
拿零分
平均下來是
一分
原本被看得一清二楚的時候
他只能拿一分
分數沒改
數也沒改
只是對方看不見了
他就從一分變成二分
這裡有一條規則
聽起來很小
被同一條虛線連起來的點
能選的選項數量必須一樣多
如果一個點有三個選項
另一個點只有兩個
那個人低頭數一數
手上有幾個選項
就知道自己站在哪裡
虛線就白畫了
接著Paul Larker把求讀困境畫成數
囚徒困境就是
兩個人都顧自己
結果兩個人都變差那個遊戲
他先讓一個人先動
再讓另一個人先動
兩棵樹長得不一樣
攤開成表格卻一模一樣
是同一個賽局
他給這一段下了一句結論
關鍵是資訊
不是時間
他還借了美國水門案
留下來的那句話
這個人知道什麼
他是什麼時候知道的
有了虛線
一棵樹你可以同時
有看得見的地方
也有看不見的地方
這時候要怎麼算
Paul Locke發現
上甲學院納許均衡
放到這種樹上會出問題
納許均衡的意思是
每個人都已經選了
對自己最好的做法
沒有人想改
可是在這種樹上
他會留下一些
說不過去的答案
第十九
查克
他讓全班分成兩邊
玩一個
他取名叫
別搞砸的小遊戲
第一個人先選往上走
或者直接離開
往上走
第二個人再選
那第一個人
還要再選一次
抖著算
大家都往上走
每個人都拿比較多
大部分同學也這樣走
可是有一些人
一開始就離開了
他們不是不會算
是怕對方搞砸
自己最後吃虧
這種擔心
也能湊出一個
納取均衡
只是他要求某個人在後面做一件事
他真的走到那一步絕對不會做的
所以Polak先給了一個名字
Sub Game
中文叫紫賽局
指的是樹裡面自己就能成立的一個小局面
再定一個新標準
Sub Game
Perfect Equilibrium
中文叫紫賽局完美均衡
他要求在每一個紫賽局裡
大家做的都是那個局面最好的選擇
說穿了
這就是終極那句話的正式版本
說出口的每一步
走到那一刻都還算數
紫賽局完美均衡怎麼找
Polak用一對老朋友示範
還記得Nina跟David嗎
上集他們約看電影
宗甲約出去玩
兩次都沒碰到面
這次
Paulak請助教Jack湯美人
Jack可以不管他們
也可以出錢送他們去上同一堂大課
讓他們坐在一起
一堂講冷戰
一堂講中國
可是Jack犯了跟Paulak一樣的錯
沒告訴他們去哪一堂
碰到面
Jack開心沒碰到
Jack白花錢
算法是這樣
先算裡面那一局
也就是兩個人怎麼選課
再把那一局的結果帶回外面
看Jack要不要送
如果Jack相信他們會選同一堂
送他們去就划算
可是裡面那一局還有一種結果
兩個人都用混的
中甲算過 這樣九次理由五次碰不到面
如果Jack相信他們會這樣混 送出去 平均是賠的
他就不該送 那天Jack決定送
David說 我讓步 去上中國
Nina也選了中國
全班鼓掌 他們終於碰到面了
先算裡面那一局
再帶回外面
這個算法最有用的地方在商場上
Polak說
這一題你下星期去投資銀行面試
很可能會碰到
有兩家做肥料的公司
A跟B
賣一樣的東西
各自決定要生產多少
現在有人拿著一臺機器來找A
這臺機器只有A能用
B借不到
租金一年70萬
他能讓A每生產一噸的成本
直接砍掉一半
問題只有一句
這臺機器該不該租
Polak要全班舉手
他說面試的時候不能棄權
所以這裡也不準棄權
結果全班大概一半一半
住在樓上的幾位企業管理碩士
也就是NBA活生投了租
Polak說
我們把這題算三次
每一次你都注意我哪裡算錯
你也可以先猜猜看
自己會投哪一邊
第一次是會計師的算法
照現在的產量
每一噸省下一半的成本
一年省50萬
租金70萬
比省下的多
所以不租
Paulak開會計師的玩笑
他說會計師通常很無聊
也常常算錯
而且無聊的時候
比算錯的時候多
這個算法錯在一個假設
他假設你租了機器以後
產量不變
可是成本降了
多做一噸還是有賺頭
你會多做一點
第二次是修過經濟學原理的人
他會把多做的那塊利潤補進去
Paulak在黑板上畫出來
會計師算的是一個長方形
漏掉的是旁邊一個三角形
他說會計師比較方正
所以常常漏掉三角形
補上去以後
這臺機器一年值69萬
全班安靜了一下
因為租金是70萬
你已經算得比會計師細很多
連自己會怎麼改都算進去了
答案還是不租
這時候兩種專業
兩種算法都投了不租
第三次是賽局理論的算法
他只多算一件事
對手也會動
前排一位同學說出來了
B也會改變他的產量
租機器這個動作B看得見
B看到A的成本降了
就知道A接下來會多做
B最好的反應
是自己少做一點
市場上的貨變少
價格就沒掉那麼多
這一塊好處進了A的口袋
先算裡面那一局
也就是租了以後兩家怎麼競爭
再把結果帶回外面
加上這一塊
這臺機器一年值100萬
比70萬多
太豬了
那幾位NBA猴生是對的
答案翻過來
靠的不是A自己多做了多少
是B退了一步
Polak說
做策略決定
最常見的錯就是
忘了它是策略
忘了別人會因為你的動作改變做法
他舉了兩個例子
政府改稅率
如果只拿大家現在的行為去算稅收
就會算錯
因為稅改
大家就跟著改
Hotel改課程規定也一樣
學生也是玩家
規則一改
他們選客的方式就變了
我們先停一下
把第一部分收起來
這一部分的問題是
看不到對方心理的時候
原本那套到底算還能不能用
答案是能用
可是要多算一件事
每個人在那一刻看得見什麼
看到以後會怎麼動
最後通牒裡
Noah心理的面子你看不到
可是她的搖頭
讓你看到了
殺架的時候你看不到對方多急
所以你用拒絕
告訴她你不急
黑板上那條虛線
分數一分沒改
只是看不見了
結果就從一變二
豬雞器那一題
關鍵是B看得見你豬了
如果前面哪一段沒跟上
記住這一句就夠了
重要的不是誰先動
是誰在那一刻看得見什麼
還有一把工具要帶著走
只賽局完美均衡
每一個小局都要算得通
下一部分
Polak要用這把工具問一個更難的問題
對方說他會怎麼做
你要不要信
第20寶可
Polak拿出現金
規則是這樣
每一輪
兩個人同時寫下一個字
打
或者退
只要有一個人寫退
遊戲就結束
還在打的那個人拿走獎品
獎品是一塊錢
可是隻要兩個人同一輪都寫打
兩個人各付75分
注意是兩個人都負 不是輸的人負
每個人後面還坐著一位同學當裁判
確認你真的寫了什麼
第一組
Polak找了兩個德州人
Nick跟Alec
兩張紙條一亮
兩個人都寫退
Polak看著他們說
德州人那股不服輸的精神跑哪去了
第二組是美式足球隊對上棒球隊
足球隊寫打 棒球隊寫退
一輪就結束
第三組才是重頭戲
Andy來自紐約
Gerson來自紐澤西
兩個人都寫打
第一輪,
兩個人都打,
各付75分,
第一輪還是都打,
到這裡,
每個人付掉的錢已經超過獎品了,
就算對方下一輪投降你把愛快錢整個拿走,
你還是虧的。
第三輪都打
第四輪還是都打
這時候Paulak讓他們講話
他說你們可以互相喊話
只是不準拿橋跟隧道互相挖苦
紐約那位說
我不能讓紐澤西贏
這是紐約人的面子
紐澤西那位說
我會一直打下去
所以你最好現在放棄
第五輪
兩張紙條打開
還是都打
Paulak喊停
他說再打下去
我的午餐就有著落了
這一段對話值得停一下
兩個人說的其實是同一句話
我是會打到底的人
你退吧
Paulak說
他們都想讓對方相信自己會打
好逼對方退
可是這種話不用花錢
兩個人都說得出口,所以誰都沒被說服
嘴上說的誰都能說
這一句我們先留著,第三部分會回來
打完之後,Paulak問紐約那位
你為什麼一直打
他說,他第二輪還跟我打的時候
我就知道反正要賠錢了
那不如繼續打,打到他退為止
Paulak說,這句話裡有兩件事
要分開看
一件是面子,我就是要贏
另一件完全不一樣
那叫Sun Cost
中文叫沉沒成本
他指的是已經付出去
再也拿不回來的錢
Paulak說
這一半的推理完全正確
打了十輪,賠掉十次75分
就是七塊半
這筆錢已經沒了
不會因為你現在退出就回來
所以打到第十輪的時候
眼前的局面
跟第一輪開始的時候一模一樣
一樣是一塊錢的獎品
一樣是下一輪要不要打
過去付的錢
在往前算的時候
一分都不用算進去
這也是為什麼一場仗
可以燒掉比獎品多很多的錢
每一輪單獨看
繼續打都說得過去
紐約隊紐澤西
這種仗有名字叫Wall of Attrition
中文叫消耗戰
他的意思是
兩邊每一輪都在付代價
看誰先放棄
Polak那天真正想證明的是
就算兩個人都很清醒
你不講面子也不管名聲
只看那一塊錢
仗還是可能打很久
他先找固定的做法
答案只有兩種
一個人永遠打 另一個人一開始就退
Polak說
如果我知道明天這場仗我會贏
那我今天就已經贏了
對手知道你會打到底
最好的做法就是馬上退
所以在這種答案裡根本沒有仗
要真的打起來
得回到中夾那把工具
混合策略
兩個人各自用一個機率決定今天打不打
這個機率要剛好讓對方覺得打跟退一樣划算
中夾那句話又回來了
混在裡面的分數一樣高
這樣一來
每一輪都有機會
兩個人同時寫打
仗就繼續
獎品越大
打的幾率越高
打一輪越貴
打的幾率越低
這不只是教室裡的遊戲
Polak舉了兩個例子
第一個是
第一次世界大戰的西線
德國那邊
跟英國與法國那邊
為了法國北部
跟比利時的幾小快遞
從1914年
對峙到1918年
那幾快遞本來不值多少
可是人命一直堆上去
Polak說
如果你不信
去看耶魯校園裡的
陣亡紀念碑
上面有多少耶魯人的名字
而美國只參戰了大約一年
第二個例子在商場上
英國的Sky電視
跟另一家衛星電視公司BSB
為了搶衛星電視市場打了好幾年
一邊不收錢
一邊送衛星天線
打到後來把帳算清楚
贏的那一方未來能賺的所有利潤
都賠不回這場帳燒掉的錢
Pollack最後補了一個好消息
在他算出來的答案裡
每一輪都有機會結束
所以拖得越久
還在打的機率就越低
很貴的戰會發生
只是不常發生
回到這部分的問題
紐約跟紐澤西嘴上說的話沒有讓對方退
那什麼樣的話才會讓人相信
第21浩克
Polak要回答的就是這個問題
承諾跟威脅什麼時候算數
他把囚徒困境搬回黑板
這個遊戲我們上集看過
兩個人各自選擇守信或背叛
兩個人都守信
大家都不錯
你守信他背叛他拿最多
你最慘
兩個人都背叛兩個人都沒拿到什麼
只玩一次的時候
不管對方怎麼做
背叛都比較划算
所以兩個人都背叛
大家一直有個直覺
多玩幾次應該就能合作了吧
Polak請Brook跟Patrick上來
玩兩輪
第一輪
Brooke手信
Patrick背叛
第二輪
兩個人都背叛
Brooke說
第一輪我是抱著希望
Patrick的理由才是重點
他說
這個遊戲這麼短
最後一輪背叛一定划算
所以倒數第二輪也一樣
所以第一輪也一樣
這串推理
是學生自己說出來的
Patrick說的那一串
Polak叫他Unraveling
中文可以說成
一路松到底
他用的就是第一部分
那把工具
每一個小局都要算得通
最後一輪自己就是一個小局
沒有明天
背叛最划算
既然最後一輪一定被判
倒數第二輪你手信
也換不到任何東西
所以也被判
然後是倒數第三輪
一路倒回第一輪
Pollack說
就算玩500次也一樣
你可以想成一件毛衣
最後一針的線頭一鬆
往回拉
人間可以一路鬆回開頭
這個結論很不舒服
他說的是
只要雙方都知道哪一天結束
合作連第一天都活不到
現實裡到處都是這種情況
美國人有個說法叫Lame Duck
中文叫跛腳鴨
指的是任期快結束的領導人
大家都知道他快走了
他說的話就開始沒分量
一位4月就要退休的員工
你沒辦法再用以後來要求他
只能把條件白紙黑字寫進盒子
問題出在大家都知道哪一天結束
所以Polak改了規則
這一次沒有人知道會玩幾輪
每一輪結束丟兩次NB
兩次都是正面就散場
其他情況就繼續玩
兩次都正面的機會是四分之一
所以繼續下去的機會是四分之三
這個數字就是第一部分殺架時
那個折線因子
不過在這裡他不是利息也不是耐心
Polak說得很清楚
在賽局裡明天比今天輕
最主要的理由是明天可能根本不會來
Brooke跟Patrick在上場
第一輪
布魯克背叛
Patrick手信
然後硬幣丟出兩個正面遊戲當場結束
Paulak說
這也太短了
我們就當作沒丟出來吧
我需要找一個沒那麼誠實的人來丟硬幣
全盤大笑
Patrick為什麼一開始手信
他說每一輪都有四分之三的機會在玩
繼續合作華德萊
線頭沒有最後一針
就鬆不起來
We'll cheat a little bit, okay
So we're playing a second time
Just with a little bit of cheating
I need someone less honest
換Edwina跟Ben
這一組完全不一樣
第一輪兩個人都手信
第二輪也是
第三輪還是
唸到第三輪的時候教室裡有聲音了
Polak說
大家的語氣裡帶著一點痛
第四輪Edwina背叛
全班嘆了一口氣
Polak問他為什麼
他說
都已經玩這麼多輪了
硬幣總該丟出兩個正面了吧
Polak接了一句
硬幣也會均值回歸啊
你聽得出這句話的意思
硬幣不會記得自己被丟過幾次
每一輪繼續的機會都一樣
可是Edwina心裡覺得
這段關係快到齊了
他的背叛就是一句話
我不相信還有明天
Ben聽懂了
他說
Edwina一背叛
我就覺得我們要回到互相背叛了
接下來兩個人都背叛
Paulak把Ben的做法寫成一條規則
這條規則叫Grim Trigger
中文叫冷酷出發
他的意思是
一開始合作
只要沒人背叛就一直合作
只要有人背叛過一次
從此永遠背叛
冷酷出發
能不能讓人一直合作
Paulak把這件事寫成一個比較
左邊叫誘惑
多賺的那一點
右邊是明天的差別
手信能拿到的未來
減掉被罰以後的未來
在城上明天會來的機會
左邊比右邊小
合作就站得住
用剛才那個遊戲算
背叛今天多賺一分
手信的話
以後每一輪都拿比較好的分數
背叛的話
以後永遠互相背叛
什麼都沒有
算出來明天會來的機會
只要有三分之一
合作就站得住
這個威脅為什麼可信
因為對方永遠背叛的時候
你也背叛
本來就是你最好的做法
罰者本身
也是每一個小局裡
都算得通的答案
第一部分
那把工具
在這裡又用上了
Paulak也提醒一件事
永遠手信聽起來最好
可是他連均衡都不是
如果你知道Jake
不管怎樣都手信
你當然會一直騙他
一套做法要站得住
自己就得帶著
讓人造作的理由
可是冷酷觸發
在真實世界不太好用
因為人會出錯
Paulak舉他跟Jake的例子
他們約好一個供水果
一個供蔬菜
有一天Paulak
沒戴眼鏡在蘋果裡
混進一顆爛的
Jake速如損數到1480
五根的時候數錯
少給了一根
白總是不該讓整段關係結束
Polak說
冷酷出發就是生意上的死刑
我不是要殺了Jack
是要殺掉我跟他的關係
所以他換了一種比較輕的罰法
只罰一輪
有人背叛
兩邊就互相背叛一輪
然後回到合作
罰則溫和多了
可是門檻往上跳
明天會來的機會
要有一分之一才行
這是這兩堂課裡
我最喜歡的一句
罰得越輕
越需要明天
道理不難
下一輪的損失變小了
你的更在乎以後
才抵得過今天那一點誘惑
這套算法最實用的地方
是在沒有法院幫你的時候
Paulak虛構了一個國家
叫Freedonia
名字來自一部老喜劇電影
也是一家美國公司
想把生產外包到那裡
因為當地工資便宜
行情是一
缺點是法院不太管用
合約很難執行
你得先把材料送過去
你的員工可以老實做事
理你的工資
也可以把材料賣掉
再回去做原本的工作
兩邊都賺
他真的這麼做
你告不了他
如果只合作一次
你得把工資開到
他才會選擇老實
整整多一倍
Paulak說
你去看歐洲跟美國的公司
在一些新興市場付的工資
真的看得到這麼大的差距
可是隻要加上明天
數字馬上變
老實做
下一次還會僱他
騙你一次就被開除
這段關係如果有一半的機會
工資只要一塊半就夠了
明天越可能來
你越不需要花錢買對方的老師
這一套也管到你我的生活
Paulak說
他在紐哈芬有一位固定的修車師傅
就算只是換機油
去連鎖的快速保養店比較便宜
他也一定回去找這位師傅
他要的回報是
師傅老實告訴他
這臺車是換個機油就好
還是真的要換引擎
可是等到那臺車快報廢
大家都知道他要換新車
新車又得回原廠保養
兩邊就會同時開始騙對方
他開始把車拿去便宜的地方換機油
師傅開始說
你這個離合器該換了
接著Paulak請班上大學四年級的學生站起來
再請有男女朋友的留著
他問
明年要跟另一半分隔兩地的舉手
舉手都有好幾個
Paulak說
照這個模型
這幾段關係
這學期要小心
因為繼續下去的機會變小了
大家就比較容易不老實
聽起來像玩笑
到底是同一個一段關係
能不能讓人老實
看的不是今天
是還有沒有明天
我們把第二部分收起來
這一部分的問題是
對方說他會怎麼做
你要不要信
答案是
光說不算
要看他說的話
有沒有明天壓著
紐約跟紐澤西
都喊自己會打到底
誰都沒被說服
因為這種話誰都說得出口
囚徒困境
只要大家知道哪天結束
線頭就一路送到底
最後一輪的承諾不可信
前面每一輪都跟著不可信
丟NB讓結束的日子
變得不確定
承諾跟威脅才開始算數
明天來的機會越大
越容易合作
罰得越輕
越需要明天
Edwina背叛
Ben讀得懂
他在說這段關係快到齊了
如果前面沒跟上
記住這一句
一句話能不能信
看的是他有沒有明天壓著
可是生活裡很多事沒有明天
面試只有一次
拍賣只有一次
你沒辦法拿以後去壓
這時候
拿什麼讓人相信
第23跑客
Polak從洛杉磯的餐廳說起
Polak先問
你們有多少人是洛杉磯來的
他要講洛杉磯的餐廳
1990年代後期以前
衛生機材員每年會去檢查
每一個餐廳
檢查完發一張證書
上面是一個很大的字母
AB或者C
重點是
法律沒有規定餐廳一定要掛出來
掛不掛
店家自己決定
你猜會怎麼樣
Polak說
他聽出過那裡的人講
你可以走到最油膩的那家小店
隔著滿是油脂的玻璃
看到蟑螂在上面爬
在蟑螂後面
一張證書掛在牆上
上面寫著C
最差的那一集
店家自己掛出來
你第一次聽
一定覺得哪裡怪怪的
沒有人逼他
為什麼要把自己的缺點貼在門口
這個問題的答案
就是第三部分的第一把鑰匙
你會看到一張C證
到底是這樣一步一步走的
拿到A的電一定會掛
這沒有懸念
拿到B的電會想
隔壁掛A
我這裡牆上空空的
客人會怎麼想
他會以為我是最差的C
所以B也掛
A跟B都掛出來
後面掛的只剩C
不掛就等於承認
所以C也掛
這個過程叫Informational Unraveling
中文可以叫資訊一路接到底
又是那件毛衣
只是這次
線頭從最好的那一端開始鬆
它有一個前提
這個資訊要能查證
證書是政府發的
夾不了
Paulak跟兩家公司也講了一次
一家公司要不要公開自己的成本
同學Hugh說成本低的會公開
Elec接著說中等的也會公開
Bethany補上最後一部成本最高的那家
公不公開都一樣大家已經知道了
這也是為什麼美國人的履歷上
連小學三年級當過西洋棋隊隊長都會寫
那一覽空著
看的人不會覺得你謙虛
只是會覺得你什麼都沒做
阿克奧拉說
這裡最容易忘的一件事是
沒有說話也在說話
這句話有個很好的例外
洛杉磯的觀光區餐廳就不太掛證書
為什麼
剛剛那整串推理有一個前提
看的人要知道本來就有這張證書
本地人知道 所以牆上空著
他讀得出意思 轉頭換一家
從外地來 第一次到迪士尼樂園附近吃飯的觀光客
根本不知道有這個制度
牆上空著 對他來說什麼都不是
Polak說 在那裡
你還是可以讓觀光客吃壞肚子 而且不必先告訴他們
所以沉默要能說話
聽的人得先知道 這裡本來應該有一句話
Polak接著講了福爾摩斯的故事
華森問他怎麼破案 福爾摩斯說
關鍵是那隻狗 華森說可是那隻狗沒有叫
富爾摩斯說
這真的是重點
普洛克說我們很容易變成華生
只看發生的事忘了沒發生的事
在美國
你有保持沉默的權利
英國後來改了規則
法院可以把你的沉默列入考量
這一改
那個權利還剩多少
普洛克留給全班自己想
剛剛那些資訊都能查證
可是生活裡很多話查不了
普洛克講了一家銀行
他給他取名叫波士頓無聊銀行
面試的時候他們會問你
你真的想來我們這裡上班嗎
你當然回答想
這個回答裡的資訊是零
因為每個人都會這樣回答
這家銀行的招募人員還跟Polak抱怨
耶魯學生被問到這題
會說我不知道
聽起來有點無聊
哈佛學生會帶著一份華爾街日報
剛好翻在介紹這家銀行的那一頁
Polak
再往前退一步
假設你為了證明自己是好員工
在面試的桌子上單腳跳舞
唱一首歌說我是好員工
這很丟臉
對 你有代價
可是公司還是不會相信
班上一位同學說出原因
壞員工也做得到
你丟臉 他也一樣丟臉
所以這個動作分不出誰是誰
這裡要講的東西叫Signaling,中文叫訊號
一個動作要能當訊號
光是有代價還不夠,他要對說謊的人特別貴
還記得紐約跟紐澤西嗎?
嘴上說的,誰都能說
現在多了一句,花一樣的代價,誰都花得起
或是隨便翻頁
在Boring Bank of Boston的網頁上
有時候他們會穿著
一個很不合理的帽子
說我很不合理
那什麼動作
對 說謊的人特別貴
Polak
用的是Michael Spence的模型
Spence靠這個模型拿到諾貝爾獎
模型裡有兩種員工
員工能替公司做出比較多的東西
壞員工比較少
公司看不出誰是誰
大家搶著僱人
所以認得出是好員工
就付他值得那麼多
認不出來
只好照平均付
平均比壞員工的值高一點
比好員工的值低很多
所以好員工想被認出來
壞員工寧可藏著
Spencer的答案是讀書
Polak的例子是讀企業管理碩士
也就是MBA
學費沒用
因為兩種人繳的一樣多
有用的是讀書的痛苦
看得懂Polak的版書
聽得懂他的口音
寫得完他的作業
好 員工讀一年比較輕鬆
壞員工讀一年痛苦得多
你可以把學位想成一顆石頭
同一顆石頭
好 員工搬得動
壞員工扛不動
真正分得出人的
不是石頭有多重
是他對兩種人重得不一樣
石頭要多種才分得開
Polak算了一個例子
學位讀三年
好 員工讀完
拿到好員工的薪水
扣掉三年的痛苦
還是比不讀好
所以他去讀
壞員工如果硬去讀
扣掉三年的痛苦
比不讀還差
所以他不讀
公司看到學位就認定是好員工
看到沒學位就認定是壞員工
而這個認定剛好是對的
這個結果有名字
叫Separating Equilibrium
中文叫分離均衡
意思是每一種人都照自己的算盤走
結果剛好分成兩邊
那改成一年行不行
一位叫S-man的同學說不行
只讀一年
痛苦太少
壞員工讀完還是賺
他也會去讀
大家都有學位
學位就跟在桌上跳舞一樣分不出誰是誰
Polak說
照這個模型
一年剛好夠
反過來說如果社會把學位變得很容易拿
好員工就得再去拿
第二個學位 第三個學位
Polak管這個叫學歷通貨膨脹
到最後
連開砂石車都要大學文憑
Polak
把這個模型最難聽的部分留到最後
第一 這整套流程裡
沒有人學到任何東西
好員工進去是什麼樣子
出來是什麼樣子
壞員工也一樣
中間燒掉的
是好員工好幾年的痛苦
純粹白費
他還開自己玩笑
這些浪費在哪裡
你們坐在這裡就是
我第二件事更難接受
沒有學會這套制度的時候
分不出來
每個人都照平均零三十億
有了這套制度
壞員工被認出來
只能零三十
好員工變好了
壞員工變差了
for luck
說這種制度拉大差距的方法
不是讓有錢的人更有錢
是讓比較窮的人更窮
他還說得很小心
他希望真實的大學裡
大家真的有學到東西
可是隻要教育有一部分
在當訊號
就有這個代價
那一堂課最後一句話是
要讓教育當訊號
要讓兩種人分得開
就必須有一些孩子
被留在後面
最後一堂課
Polak走進教室的
第一句話是
我那幾罐硬幣跑哪去了
他帶了兩個玻璃罐
裝滿零錢
一大一小
大的那個是青醬罐
罐子一排一排傳下去
每個人可以搖一搖看一看
先在筆記本
寫下自己猜裡面有多少錢
這時候他把整門課
都放回一條線上
他說
這學期大部分時間
我們都假設你知道對手是誰
直到他的分數
這個星期不一樣
你不知道對方心裡的數字
拍賣就是這種情況
Polak
說這種東西有個名字
叫Common Value
中文叫共同價值
意思是他對誰都值一樣多
只是每個人估的不一樣
他舉的例子是油田
裡面有多少油是固定的
每家公司試賺以後估出來的都不同
接著前兩排的同學寫下出價
這種玩法叫
First Price Sealed Bid Auction
中文叫第一價格密封投標
規則是出價最高的人得標
拿走罐子裡所有的錢
付出自己寫的數字
Paulak說
這是完整的你得標
就要付我錢
出價一個一個唸出來
註教Alley全部抄在黑板上
有人寫四塊半
也有人寫不到一塊
唸到一個一分錢的出價
Paulak停下來說
我這個罐子是有什麼問題嗎
全班笑了
最高的出價是五塊錢
得標的是Ashley
Paulak請他站起來全班給他掌聲
他說
看起來裡面大概有五塊錢
而且還附送一個罐子
Paulak說罐子我可不一定要送
然後他公佈答案
大罐子裡
一共是2.07元
Ashley花5元買到2.07元
多付了將近3元
Pluck再請大家舉手
原本估計超過1.07元的有多少人
大概將近一半
你注意
大部分人的估計不算太離譜
有高有低
散在真正的金額兩邊
出事的是那個贏的人
所以Ashley說她花了大約5塊錢
因為看起來好像有大約5塊錢
而且她拿到瓶子
而且你拿到瓶子
我不是說我拿到瓶子
為什麼會這樣
Polak在黑板上畫了一條中型的曲線
罐子裡真正的金額只有一個
每個人的估計
是真正的金額加上一點誤差
有人估高有人估低
大致平均地散在兩邊
現在問
誰會得標估得最高的那一個
估得最高也就是誤差最大的那一個
它不是從中間來的
它是從曲線最右邊那條尾巴來的
這個現象叫Winners Curse
中文叫贏家詛咒
他的意思是
贏這件事本身
就是一個關於你自己判斷的壞消息
Polak用一個想像的例子講
假設你股150個按比
我告訴你旁邊那位股130
你的數字會往下調
我只告訴你他比你低
沒說低多少
你還是會往下調
現在我告訴你
全場每一個人股的都比你低
你的數字會掉很多
而這句話就是你得標那一刻知道的事
第二次世界大戰之後
美國政府把墨西哥灣的油田開採權拿出來拍賣
得標的公司一直賠錢
股票剛上市的時候
價格也常定的太高之後往回掉
所以普拉給的規則只有一句
出價之前
先假設有人告訴你
你贏了
在那個前提下
你覺得罐子有多少錢
再比那個數字少出一點
這樣真的贏了
你也不會後悔
因為你早就把贏這件事算進去了
這個道理你其實碰過
你去談薪水
開了一個數字
對方一口就答應
那一刻你心裡會涼一下
因為開價一次就被接受
通常代表你開的太低
還記得第一部分嗎
理論說
第一個報價就會成交
到了真實世界
你的報價馬上成交
反而是一句話
他在告訴你
對方願意付的比你想的多
講完這一套
Paulak
馬上用小罐子再玩一次
得標的是Robert出價一塊六毛
小罐子裡是一塊四毛八分
Paulak問他
你原本估裡面有多少
Robert說一塊六毛
Paulak說我好像教得不太好
不過他再請大家舉手
這一次
大部分人都把出價壓到自己的估計以下了
只是Paulak說壓得還不夠
我們把第三部分收起來
這一部分的問題是
沒有明天可以壓的時候
一個動作
憑什麼讓人相信
答案有兩層
第一層
能查證的資訊會自己一路接到底
連沒掛證書連沒說話都在說話
第二層
查不了的時候
嘴巴說的沒用
在桌上跳舞也沒用
要做一件對說謊的人特別貴的事
就像那顆石頭
最後那罐硬幣再往前推一步
連你自己贏了
都是一句話他在告訴你
其他人都估得比你低
如果前面沒跟上
記住這一句
一個動作說服得了人
是因為別人假裝不來
也別忘了他的代價
Spence的模型裡
這顆石頭沒讓任何人變得更好
還讓分不出來的那些人領得更少
訊號有用
可是它不是免費的
我們回到開場那個問題
當你看不到對方心裡那件事的時候
你還能不能算
這八堂課的答案是能
而且是分三步算
第一步
算清楚每個人在那一刻看得見什麼
看到以後會怎麼動
第二步
別隻聽他說什麼
要看他的話有沒有明天壓著
第三步
沒有明天的時候
看他願意付什麼代價
連沉默
連你自己的贏都要賭
所以這一集的答案是
男的不是看穿人心
是讀懂動作
三集連起來其實是一條線
上集說
男的不是算出自己要什麼
是算出別人會怎麼做
中集說
男的不是眼前划算
是長期划算
下集說
別人會怎麼做
他心裡在想什麼
都寫在他的動作裡
1121159
那這裡就講完了
一共14朝課
Pollock最後一句話是
我們結束了
複習課見
最後問你一個問題
你做過最費力的一件事
只為了讓別人相信你
是什麼
對方後來真的相信了嗎
留言告訴我
喜歡這種把公開課講清楚的內容
也可以訂閱AI Notebook
我是Jim
我們下次見